This problem says, some people
use the letters F-O-I-L, or
FOIL, as a strategy for making
sure they have multiplied all
the terms. Use the FOIL approach
to multiply 3x plus
2, times 5x minus 7.
I'm going to let you know just
from the get-go, I personally
don't like FOIL because it's
kind of just a mnemonic to
kind of memorize steps, and
you really don't know what
you're doing.
But since this problem
says use FOIL, I
guess we'll use FOIL.
So let's just use FOIL.
So FOIL stands for-- and
that's why I hate these
mnemonics, because as soon as
you're done with the test
you're going to forget this, and
when you're 30 years old
you're not going to even
remember what FOIL stands for.
Especially how to apply it.
But it stands for first,
outside, inside, and last. And
the whole point of it is to make
sure that you multiply
every term in this first
expression with every other
term in the last expression.
Now, the reason why you're doing
it is you're really just
doing the distributive
property twice.
And I'll do that later in this
video, because I really
dislike just memorizing FOIL.
But since we have it written
there, let's do it.
So first says let's multiply
the two first terms. So
first-- let me do it in
different colors-- the first
terms, two first terms
was a 3x and a 5x.
So you multiply the
3x times the 5x.
Then the outside says multiply
the outside numbers.
So multiply the 3x and
the negative 7.
So notice, we've multiplied the
3x times the 5x, and now
we're going to multiply the
3x times the negative 7.
So plus 3x times negative 7.
That's the outside.
Then it tells you to
do the inside.
The inside numbers are
the 2 and the 5x.
So plus 2 times 5x.
And then L stands for last, or
the last numbers, or 2 times
negative 7.
Plus 2 times negative 7.
Now we just have to simplify.
3x times 5x is 15x squared, plus
3x times negative 7 is
negative 21x.
2 times 5x is 10x.
And then you have 2 times
negative 7 is negative 14.
And now we can combine these
middle two terms right here.
If I have negative 21x and then
I'm adding 10x to that,
that takes me back
to negative 11x.
So this is negative 11x.
And we have the 15x
squared out front.
15x squared minus
11x, minus 14.
Which is the product of
these two expressions.
So FOIL does give you the right
answer, but it's just
not always obvious why you're
doing all of these different
combinations of multiplications.
But this is the right answer.
But what I want to do is take
a side here to just show you
that as long as you just knew
the distributive property, you
could have done this problem.
You did not have to know FOIL.
And this way you'll
never forget it.
So if I'm going to multiply 3x
plus 2, times 5x minus 7, what
you can think about is, this is
just some number here, and
if I'm multiplying times this
expression, I can just
distribute it onto
this expression.
If this was just a, I don't
know, if this was just a 2, we
would say, OK, this is the same
thing as 2 times 5x, plus
2 times negative 7.
That's what the distributive
property is.
So let's just distribute
it out.
Let's just distribute.
We have to just multiply this
whole thing times each of
those terms. That's just the
distributive property.
So you get 3x plus
2, times 5x.
I could write the 5x
out front here.
So that's just that
times that.
And then you're going to have
plus 3x plus 2, times the
second term, times negative 7.
Now, I could just put a negative
plus here and a
negative 7.
Or I could say it's negative
7 times 3x, plus 2.
So it's 5x times 3x plus 2,
minus 7 times 3x plus 2.
This was just the distributive
property.
Now, again, we can apply the
distributive property to get
the 5x times each of these
terms. So this is going to be
5x times 3x, plus 5x, times 2.
Just doing the distributive
property on this.
Now, we do it again here, so
that we have minus 7 or
negative 7 times 3x.
And then negative 7 times 2.
So minus 7 times 2.
And what do we get?
Scroll down a little bit.
I'll do these in a
neutral color.
We get 5x times 3x
is 15x squared.
5x times 2 is 10x.
7 times 3x is minus 21x.
And then negative 7 times
2 is minus 14.
And just like we saw up here,
these two terms can be merged
into 10x minus 21x
is negative 11x.
So we get 15x squared
minus 11x, minus 14.
Could have done it just doing
the distributive property
twice, which you're less likely
to forget when you're
30 years old.
Or if you like, you
can memorize FOIL.